it's becoming the norm in Hong Kong for
11 weekend straight streams of
pro-democracy protesters on the streets
hundreds of thousands filled Victoria
Park and his surroundings
Toby Kwok and her husband have taken
part in most of the rally so far this
time they brought their two young
children my children to learn about what
is happening in Hong Kong and what we
are fighting for I want them to
experience this in person rather than
just us telling them what's right and
what is wrong
it is a historical moment many others
also said they came to denounce the
police crackdown on protesters and put
pressure on a government they feel is
ignoring them with each week that passes
anger increases and the divide of the
government grows deeper and so from the
initial demand of revoking the
extradition bill now there are 5 demands
that the protesters here say they won't
back down from among the demands
democratic reform and the withdrawal of
criminal charges against more than 700
protesters who have been detained so far
but for Justine and Joey
there is one demand that takes priority
I think it's the police brutality they
have to have investigation about it
otherwise
the people who live here they will not
feel safe have no leader we just feel
like really walking in the dark
is this really frustrating and scared
journey for us for me I cannot be for
anyone but for me just feeling really
lost authorities had only granted
permission for a rally in the park but
despite the heavy rain they marched on
the streets and some took their
grievances yet again to the seat of Hong
Kong central government laser pointers
have become a sign of defiance for some
demonstrators veterans of the street
protest after three turbulent months
among them Ranger not his real name who
says he's ready to fight if need be our
decisions are based on police moves if
they plan to arrest protesters we will
take action because we are united and we
don't want anyone to be detained
we don't confront them if they don't
harass us previous protests have seen
clashes between activists and police but
this weekend's rally ended peacefully
Ranger and his friends melted away with
the crowd it won't be long before
they're back on the streets of Hong Kong
hood abdel hamid al jazeera honk-honk